en medio de las recientes victorias del
movimiento provida en la corte suprema
de justicia de eeuu la administración de
drogas y alimentos eliminó la regulación
que prohibía recetar píldoras abortivas
mediante consultas por internet o
telemedicina y enviarlas así por correo
a los pacientes concretamente los
medicamentos que se podrán empezar a
usar son mifepristona y misoprostol
según la afe de la mifepristona se usa
para interrumpir embarazos en más de 60
países incluidos al menos 14 países de
europa este medicamento está aprobado
como seguro y eficaz para la
interrupción de embarazos hasta 10
semanas después de la gestación además
la fd a estima que 37 millones de
mujeres tomaron el medicamento entre
2000 y 2018 cabe resaltar que la droga
no está disponible legalmente en
internet para compra de cualquiera sino
que los proveedores de esta se tendrán
que registrar con los fabricantes
previamente y la tendrán que almacenar
ellos mismos esto podría incluso de
salem dar a algunos médicos para recetar
el aborto por medicamento hay que
mencionar también que varios estados han
prohibido la distribución de esta droga
y han impuesto restricciones en su uso
pero precisamente este clima restrictivo
está aumentando los abortos
autogestionados que evitan así la
interacción con el sistema de salud en
eeuu